so steve bannon just got arrested also
billy eilish endorsed joe biden from a
graveyard hillary clinton returns to
lament her fate and a viciously partisan
barack obama steals the night
from low energy kamala i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn surf the web with peace of
mind sign up now at expressvpn.com
then we'll get to all the news in just a
moment first we need to talk about being
responsible you know it's a responsible
thing to do right now
saving money you know it's an
irresponsible thing to do getting
unlimited data on your phone that you
don't use and spending too much money on
that that's just a silly thing to do
this is why you should be using
puretalk usa who is your wireless
provider att
verizon t-mobile what if i told you that
pure talk usa uses the exact same
network as one of those carriers same
towers same coverage but literally cost
you half the price
how do they make it affordable well no
retail stores low overhead you're not
funding billion dollar ad campaigns
you're only paying for the data you need
and that's the big one no contract no
excessive fees you enjoy unlimited
talk text and two gigs of data all for
just 20 bucks a month so you could be
saving like 400 bucks a year on your
wireless bill by using puretalk usa
and in a time of economic turmoil now
would be a very good time to cut down on
that cell phone bill grab your mobile
phone
now pound 250 and say ben shapiro when
you do
you get this amazing deal and save 50
off your first month again that is pound
2 5 0 say keyword ben shapiro for that
special deal say 50
off your first month and again this
thing is costing you like 20 bucks a
month instead of a multiple
of that go check out pure talk usa today
by texting pound
two five zero and saying keyword ben
shapiro to get started okay so
before we get to all of the convention
related news and it was
a stilted awkward
overwrought evening last night for the
democratic party it looked much more
like a typical
dnc event meaning it was kind of a
star-studded affair with various
hollywood celebrities telling you how
you should feel about politics which
definitely has
mainstream appeal in places like
wisconsin ohio pennsylvania
and you definitely need to hear from
billy eilish about why you should vote
if you're if you are
a rural voter living in wisconsin huge
huge the billy irish endorsement there
was a lot of that there was there was
barack obama showing up hillary clinton
showed up
it was basically the cavalcade of old
democratic stars
and then kamala harris shows up and was
utterly lackluster we'll get to that in
a second first
we have to break the news breaking news
as of this morning that former senior
trump adviser steve bannon who's his
former campaign
president co-chair was arrested thursday
and charged with what federal
prosecutors said was his role in a
scheme to have brought hundreds of
thousands of donors
in connection with an online
crowdfunding campaign this is according
to the wall street journal
the campaign known as we build the wall
raised more than 25 million
according to prosecutors from the
southern district of new york which
brought the charges
the acting u.s attorney audrey strauss
said as alleged the defendants defrauded
hundreds of thousands of donors
capitalizing on their interest in
funding a border wall to raise millions
of dollars
under the false pretense that all of the
money would be spent on construction
in addition to bannon the indictment
charges brian colfage andrew batalato
and timothy shea
with one count of conspiracy to commit
wire fraud and one count of conspiracy
to commit money laundering
each charge carries a maximum of 20
years in
prison since december 2018 the four men
convinced people to donate to the
campaign telling the public they quote
do not take a penny in salary or
compensation and that 100 of the funds
raised will be used in execution of our
mission
and purpose and uh bannon stated
publicly we are a volunteer organization
so as always innocent until proven
guilty
um and uh i have many comments here on a
personal level about steve bannon if you
don't know what i think of steve bannon
feel free to go back about four years
when i was the first person in america
to say what i thought about steve bannon
who was in fact my old boss at breitbart
um i'm not a fan i think it is fair to
say
that i was maybe the first person in
america to point out that steve bannon
is uh the worst person i personally know
but even the worst people i personally
know are entitled to their day in court
and so we will simply leave it at that i
just would be remiss if i did not
at least make a brief comment on that
news since it is leading the newscast
everywhere today and i don't want people
to think that i'm simply ignoring it i'm
not ignoring it i'm just um
refraining from deeper comments about my
thoughts on steve bannon all of which
are available
for several years on the program and i
will leave it at that okay now to the
actual
big news of the of the day and that was
night three of the democratic
national convention it was barack
obama's night barack obama still
dominates the democratic party that is
the reason that joe biden is the nominee
but it was a very awkward night because
barack obama
basically appointed kamala harris's
successor in fact he even said this
originally he was supposed to close out
tonight as the last sitting president
he was the la he was supposed to close
out tonight it was pretty unprecedented
to do what he had done
and when i say unprecedented i mean for
probably 80 years the former president
of the united states does not
go on full-scale political attack on
their successor right george w bush
didn't do this about barack obama
bill clinton actually kind of refrained
from doing this about george w bush h.w
didn't do it about clinton
reagan didn't do it about either hw or
clinton and
this has been true for quite a while is
that people who are formerly president
generally tend not to go around
badmouthing the people who are
their successors unless your name is
jimmy carter and you obnoxiously walk
around for decades on end
lamenting about how terrible ronald
reagan was after end of the cold war but
that's more of an outlier okay well
barack obama last night made the night
all about him
it didn't really help kamala harris that
he went before because he's a much
better speaker than kamala harris
also he said that he wanted to go before
kamal harris to hand her the baton
which is kind of weird since she's not
the one running for president
right except barack obama man that guy
really doesn't like joe biden very much
i mean they always talk about
he's uh we're brothers we're brothers so
i sat out this entire election cycle i
waited until after the whole thing was
settled
and then i was like you know what i like
joe biden sure i told him to stay out in
2016.
sure i didn't endorse him in 2020. and
now i'm appointing my successor
kamala harris and kama's like and joe
biden's off in the corner being like uh
joe
um but i'm i'm joe i'm joe i'm joe
biden's husband and i'm i'm the one
running for
uh so once again joe biden
after thought at his own birthday party
so that is that is kind of sad
we'll get to that but we begin with the
celebrity endorsements
so for some reason the democrats keep
thinking that if they tried out
celebrities this is going to be deeply
affecting to millions of americans
and it's a weird take it's a very weird
take there's one thing that americans
like about their celebrities and it's
when they perform right they like when
celebrities perform and do what they're
doing right
if you want to watch a basketball game
you want to watch the basketball players
play the basketball game you don't
really want to hear them
comment about politics if you want to
watch a rock star you want to hear the
rockstar do his thing you don't want to
hear the rockstars politics
this is true in every arena of american
life unless you are explicitly in
politics people generally are not
interested in hearing your take on the
political news of the day and so it's
bewildering to me that so many hollywood
celebrities think that people are
hinging
are just hinging on their every word
that people are just
sitting there waiting with bated breath
to hear what billy eilish thinks about
politics
i will admit i'm not a billy eilish
aficionado i know this comes as a great
shock to many of you
as pop culture savvy as i obviously am i
know that it comes to major shock to you
that i had no clue
who billy eilish was other than she
looked like a person
on the front of an ad for xanax
in all of her in all of her marketing
materials that's pretty much all i knew
about her
so we're going to play a song from her
in a second i'll evaluate but i mean i
literally have never heard the billy
either song
which is because i stopped listening to
music in like 1875 or so
um but billy eilish gave her message at
the dnc because you need to hear
from an 18 year old about how you should
vote
so billy eilish and and i mean it's a
weird optic i will say
this is a very strange optic so first of
all it seems like it's a little on the
nose for her to do her endorsement of
joe biden from an actual graveyard
that seems a little bit on the nose like
you can see there's like a tree behind
her she's in like a haunted
graveyard and you expect joe biden to
kind of
like the crypt keeper emerge from a
grave
to receive his his plaudits at her hands
but and she looks kind of depressed
right she's supposed to be making an
uplifting appeal to why you should vote
why it's important to vote
but you'd be depressed too if you had
just lost you've just been slimed on
double dare and then you were forced to
give
an endorsement of an 80 year old man in
a graveyard you'd be depressed too
here's billy eilish giving probably the
least
inspiring endorsement of a major
politician i have ever seen in my entire
life it was it was really
uh you know trump likes to say low
energy low energy
almost captures it here's billy eilish a
really inspiring
uplifting energetic tone to this one
donald trump is destroying our country
and everything
we care about we need leaders who will
solve
problems like climate change and kovid
not deny them
leaders who will fight against systemic
racism and inequality
and that starts by voting for someone
who understands how much is at stake
someone who's building a team that
shares our values
it starts with voting against donald
trump and
for joe biden silence is not an option
and we cannot sit this one out
we all have to vote like our lives and
the world depend on it
because they do okay i'm not accusing
billy eilish of uh
drug use here at all i'm not i really am
not all i'm saying is the vibe here is
the exact same vibe that you get when
you're at a party and people are smoking
dope
uh and i have been i have not smoked the
dope myself it's very awkward for me i'm
just that guy who sits in the corner
reading a russell kirk book but
it is uh that that was the vibe there
and again billy eilish
after having been slammed losing the
physical challenge on double dare from a
graveyard endorsing the 77 year
old weird vibe weird vibe dnc okay so
then billy eilish sang a song
it was a new song i've never heard it
but i wouldn't know her new songs from
her old songs because i've never heard
billy eiler's song so what did that
sound like
let's say maybe she's really talented i
mean maybe let's let's give it a listen
[Music]
um this is like surprisingly poppy an
upbeat for a person who looks as though
she's very depressed all the time i mean
this is wow
okay so i mean that's mildly enjoyable
i'm just not awful
again weird vibe but okay if that's what
you think is going to get your voters
out
in like the in pennsylvania
sure sure dnc sure they also brought out
kerry washington
who was last relevant what three four
years ago when she did a show
uh well what's she in machine scandal i
can't remember which show she was in
in any case she showed up because i
definitely needed to hear from carrie
washington
like don't they have bigger like billy
eilish is a pretty big celebrity but
kerry washington is really not neither
is eva longoria like couldn't they
gotten tom hanks or something
you figured they would have at least
made the appeal here was uh here was
kerry washington yesterday saying we're
fighting for our lives okay i i'm so
tired of the language they are fighting
for your life
you're literally not fighting for your
life this is the most civilized
free and prosperous country in the
history of the world kerry washington is
not fighting for her life
okay i'm sorry but kerry washington is a
very very wealthy
person in the united states a very
wealthy and privileged person
and the fact that she is black does not
change any of that she's not fighting
for her life and billy eilish is not
fighting for her life none of these
people are fighting for their lives this
all reminds me
the overwrought nature of this is so
bizarre it reminds me of this there's an
onion headline from the onion
years ago where they used to have point
counterpoint columns and the point
was something so this the one that comes
to mind is there there was a point
point of view and it showed like a 17
year old girl making a face and saying
i'm starving
and then on the other side it showed
like a rwandan child holding their
stomach and saying i'm starving
right and the point obviously is first
world problems there are people
on planet earth who actually have
problems if you're speaking at the dnc
and then you go back home to your
mansion you're not fighting for your
life
you're not so can we cut this crap
seriously it destroy
i don't like it on the right i don't
like it on the left the alarmism that
the country is like
the the country we're all on the verge
of doom
we're not on the verge of doom okay
there are serious ideological risks in
the country
i think the destruction of the american
ideal is is gradually been put on the
table
i'm scared about that but do i think
that everybody's like in actual fear of
their life being put in danger in the
united states right now
based on an election not unless you're
living in a major city and riots are
being allowed
but here is kerry washington with the
your life depends on it your life
depends on it from kerry washington
from billy eilish he's extraordinarily
rich celebrities sure sure i'm sure that
kerry washington
is living every day in great fear that
donald trump is going to come to our
house and do something terrible
our union is not without flaws when our
constitution was written
women couldn't vote black people were
considered
three-fifths of a human being but
therein
lies the work no one is perfect
nothing is but it is the striving toward
justice equality and truth
that distinguishes us we fight for a
more perfect union
because we are fighting for the soul of
this country
and for our lives you're not fighting
for your life
you're not okay stop just stop
okay because then then you get that okay
so when you combine the message that
you're fighting for your life
with the election's gonna be stolen from
you that starts to see it actually
dangerous
and that's true again on both sides okay
we're gonna get to more from
night three of the dnc in just one
second first
let us talk about the fact that right
now hiring can be pretty complicated
there's a lot of uncertainty about where
the market is going that means that you
need to get the best people this is
where ziprecruiter comes in
ziprecruiter sends your jobs to over 100
of the web's leading job sites but they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people
with the right experience and actively
invites them to apply to your job
ziprecruiter makes the entire hiring
process efficient and effective with
features like screening
questions to filter candidates and an
all-in-one dashboard where you can
review and rate your candidates zip
recruiter in fact is so effective that
four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the very first day
right now to try zip recruiter for free
my listeners can go to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
zip recruiter.com daily wires if
recruiters indeed the smartest way to
hire which is why we've been using it
here
for a long time it's why all of our
employees live under under the tacit
threat
of losing their job to a more qualified
candidate
let's say for example that your producer
nick and you knew that i had no idea who
billy eilish was
and yet you continued to make a bunch of
billy song title jokes to me
for like minutes on end right before the
show well you might find yourself zip
recruited go check out ziprecruiter.com
dailywire right now that zip
recruiter.com dailywire
go check them out right now okay so the
dnc
night three was the first time they
actually laid out some of the radical
positions their most radical position is
of course they are very much in favor
of gun control so joe biden pushed a
video about how much he loved
gun control right and this video
featured emma gonzalez and the
and the kids from march for our lives
you know doing doing the whole
we demand action everything that every
the second amendment doesn't exist
routine if you ever think that the
democrats aren't radical on this issue
all you have to do is watch their
convention
like i don't know which swing voters in
the swing states they're going for with
this one
but apparently they think this is a
popular position which is weird so they
played this video at the dnc last night
featuring
emma gonzalez probably the most radical
member of the march for our lives crowd
they say that tougher gun laws do not
decrease gun violence
we call bs
they say a good guy with a gun stops a
bad guy with a gun
we call
[Applause]
they say guns are just tools like knives
we
call b okay i mean this is irritating at
the time it's even more irritating when
you play it
from the from the rostrum of the dnc
even if it's an online dnc
and just the pitch that is being made
there is a bunch of tautological
statements that happen to be true
and then you just shout we call bs
gravity draws objects closer to larger
objects
we call bs okay just cause you call bs
doesn't mean that it's actually bs
in any case this was one of the big
messages of the dnc last night they
brought forth a gun control activist as
well to say that president trump does
not care if people get shot
which is one of my favorite things about
the democratic party we have to take the
high road the high road is
we imply that our opponents literally do
not care if people die they've been
doing this about kobe trump doesn't care
if people die of covet trump doesn't
care if people get shot
trump doesn't you know who doesn't care
it seems to me it seems to me that no
one at the dnc
for three long nights has mentioned the
fact that there are ongoing riots in
portland
and seattle that there are riots in
chicago dc new york
los angeles three nights of this and not
one mention of it in fact glorification
of that by contrast it's pretty amazing
but apparently it is of course everybody
on the right who's uncaring if we
disagree on gun policy
this is a long ongoing stick from the
left it is very irritating
i thought i had debunked it when i told
piers morgan that you really shouldn't
stand on the graves of victims
in order to castigate the political
position of your opponents but
apparently this is what they're going to
continue to do so that was trotted out
last night
president trump he doesn't care he
didn't care about the victims
after parkland las vegas
or el paso i want a president
who cares about our pain and grief
a president who will take on the gun
lobby to ban assault weapons
and close the loopholes to keep guns out
of the hands of criminals
joe biden has taken on the nra twice and
won
and he will do it again as president
okay well worthwhile noting that um him
taking on the nra and quote unquote
winning did not actually involve them
winning more guns have now been sold in
the united states
than any time in american history more
more guns are in circulation than any
time in american history so giant fail
if you're a gun control advocate okay so
that was sort of the lead up
then we got to the prime time the prime
time featuring
all of the democrats big stars so many
big stars
for example hillary clinton made her big
return to lament the fact that
life has been unkind and cruel to
hillary clinton
she was back to serve as a warning to
all of you
she returned from the woods of chappaqua
after a long time in exile
to tell you that people tell me all the
time they have regrets
they have regrets now remember hillary
clinton is the same person
who asked about this and she's like
people will come up to me and they'll
say they regret not voting for me i'm
like what the
by the way is at least an honest take
here is hillary clinton from chapaqua
new york now i assume this was filmed
not
at the same time as bill clinton filmed
his little little speech from chapaqua
new york because
i believe she has a restraining order
against him they're sort of like
the the same side of the magnet they
they are they're poles
and if you bring the the positive side
of the magnet toward another positive
side of the magnet they just repel
they they have to stay outside of a
certain mile radius of one another let's
the universe implode
from their hatred of one another in any
case here was hillary clinton saying
people tell me they have regrets regrets
i've got a few
for four years people have told me
i didn't realize how dangerous he was i
wish i could do it all over
or worse i should have voted
look this can't be another woulda coulda
shoulda election
if you vote by mail request your ballot
now and
send it back right away if you vote in
person
do it early become a poll worker
most of all no matter what vote
my god she's magnetic i cannot believe
she lost to donald trump
what a magnetic politician it would take
a heart of stone
not to laugh at this and fortunately for
you i don't have
a heart of stone she also lamented she
said you can win by three million votes
and still lose
so here she is prepping the argument the
democratic argument by the way is trump
is trying to undermine the legitimacy of
the election here's hillary clinton
again undermining the legitimacy of the
election
vote for honest elections so we not a
foreign adversary
choose our president vote for the
diverse
hopeful america we saw in last night's
roll call and don't forget
joe and kamala can win by 3 million
votes and still lose take it from me
so we need numbers overwhelming so trump
can't sneak or
steal his way to victory take it from me
i have been out here in the wilderness
pretending i'm president
for years and it's getting old i'll be
honest with you
uh hillary clinton and then she of
course uh
saved uh saved over some of her bile
from the last election cycle to talk
about
donald trump i i do love when hillary
clinton does the more in sadness than an
anger routine
she is so bitter about the 20 i mean
listen i'd be bitter too right if i won
the popular vote by three million and
then didn't end up president i'd be kind
of pissed as well if i'd spent my entire
waking adult life wanting to be
president and then i lost to
somebody i considered a reality tv star
clown because i didn't visit wisconsin
i'd be kind of ticked as well but here
was hillary clinton reserving her bile
for donald trump
saying that she wishes that trump knew
how to be president
you know like she knew how to be
president but isn't or like her husband
knew how to be president when he was um
using the oval office for particular
purposes here was hillary clinton
if he had put his own interests and ego
aside
seeing the humanity in a child ripped
from her parents at the border
or a protester calling for justice or a
family wiped out by natural disaster
that would have been a good thing for
america and the world
i wish donald trump knew how to be a
president
because america needs a president right
now
okay i just want to point out that when
she says i wish that donald trump knew
how to put
his inhumanity and ego aside
inhumanity and ego that was basically
hillary clinton's entire career-long
slogan
hillary clinton not famous for being the
most human candidate and certainly
the only reason that she was even up for
the job is because of her unbelievable
ego trip that alienated so many
americans donald trump ended up
being president she concluded by saying
what do you have to lose you have
everything to lose
you know donald trump said what do you
have to lose and the answer is you have
everything
to lose all the things so here's hillary
clinton blaming everything
on planet earth on president trump
as michelle obama and bernie sanders
warned us
if trump is re-elected things will get
even worse
that's why we need unity now more than
ever
remember back in 2016 when trump asked
what do you have to lose
well now we know our health care our
jobs
our loved ones our leadership in the
world
and even our post office oh the post
office guys
we have to we have to uphold the po we
know i love mailboxes
mailboxes are great okay so that
charmless human being
um as decided by the american people
circa 2016.
uh so she returned that's not a great
look for the democrats because she's
kind of charmless right i mean
the fact is that they could not drag her
over the finish line but she was not the
only person to be brought up
so last night was also women's night at
the dnc a lot of focus on women because
kamala harris
is the vp nominee and so he got to hear
from other luminaries like nancy pelosi
and elizabeth warren so none of them by
the way were the star of the show but
we'll get to what they had to say
as well the gaslighting at the dnt is
truly incredible it really is you have
hillary clinton
making the appeal for unity over ego
okay and then wait till you get to obama
i mean just the enormous
hypocrisy is is pretty pretty telling
we'll get some more of this in one
second first
would you like to know the secret to
staying sweat free this summer i would
because it is like 104 degrees outside
well yesterday i actually worked out
in the tremendous tremendous heat but
you know what i was still saying
staying cool because i had tommy john
underwear
tommy john's ultra breathable underwear
they also have bras for the ladies they
have a range of summer ready breathable
options they're cool cotton underwear
for men and women it's like having your
own on-body ac
tommy john's cool cotton is made from
premium natural pima cotton for enhanced
airflow it evaporates sweat super fast
keeping you dryer cooler and more
comfortable than regular cotton
if you want to add some chill to the
butt when summer heats up chews tommy
john
cool cotton underwear other layers are
built for next level comfort by the way
they have stuff beyond underwear and
it's just fantastic whether you're on
the hunt for lounge pants or lazy day
joggers or the softest zoom ready t's
and polos you've ever worn
tommy john has got you covered their
stuff is just fantastic i'm not the only
person who loves tommy john
my wife loves tommy john products as
well tommy john is so confident in their
underwear if you don't love your first
pair you can get a full refund with
their best pair you'll ever wear or it's
free
guaranteed for a limited time go to
tommyjohn.com ben get twenty percent off
your first order that is tommyjohn.com
ben for twenty percent off again
tommyjohn.com
ben go check them out right now okay so
other luminaries showed up nancy pelosi
showed up
and again she makes the pitch this is
the big pitch for the democrats because
here's the thing things were going
pretty well until covered
they were you had donald trump going on
twitter and making an ass of himself but
other than that things were going pretty
well the economy was really booming on
the foreign policy front
a lot of progress was being made in the
middle east a lot of progress was being
made versus china
but then covet hit and so the entire
democratic playbook here
is keep the gov keep everything shut
down like as much as possible shut down
blame trump for that and then blame
trump for all the deaths that have
happened it doesn't matter that
that really is inaccurate on every level
doesn't matter by the way that there's
no apparent standard for reopening
anywhere i mean this is pretty
incredible
new york city yesterday had zero deaths
from covet and 64 total diagnosed cases
and the city is still shut down
they're in what they call stage four of
reopening which means that restaurants
are still
not open and hair salons are still not
open there is no stage five
so it's indefinite i mean they're just
gonna keep it like that in new york
despite the fact they have
zero count them zero deaths yesterday
and 64 total cases in a county of 1.6
million people
there is no standard for reopening for
the democratic
governors and then they are praised to
the skies by the media
for all this so the democratic playbook
is keep everything locked down as much
as you possibly can
blame trump for all the death even
though those cities like new york city
just absolutely got walloped and are
governed by blue
okay nancy pelosi is withholding aid
right now
republicans are trying to push forward a
relief package for people who are still
on unemployment nancy pelosi is holding
that up
yet there she was at the dnc last night
suggesting that the republicans
don't want to crush the virus that they
don't want to crush
so she's just blaming republicans for
covet 19 which is
a pretty astonishing and remarkable and
horrific
claim actually more than 5 million
americans are infected by the
coronavirus
over 170 000 have died
the science-based action the heroes act
we enacted three months ago
is essential to safeguard lives
livelihood
and the life of our democracy and who is
standing in the way
mitch mcconnell and donald trump instead
of crushing the virus
they're trying to crush the affordable
care act and it's pre-and
pre-existing conditions benefit um
they're the ones trying to pass a relief
package that you have now delayed
several times
speaker pelosi mainly her pitch comes
down to trump is a very very bad bad
mean man again the entire dnc when you
boil it all the way down is really they
don't like trump and trump's mean
and which means which means that if
trump had any discipline at all he'd
actually be able to win this election
as we'll see the president's lack of
discipline is not helping him right now
but here was pelosi
basically making her pitch which is
trump is mean and bad and mean and
orange and bad and fat and mean and
orange
the speaker of the house i've been i've
seen firsthand donald trump's disrespect
for facts
for working families and for women in
particular
disrespect written into his policies
toward our health and our rights
not just his conduct but we know what he
doesn't
that when women succeed america succeeds
okay so he's a sexist too right so that
was the pitch going in for kamala harris
is that he's a sexist he's a racist
that's why he doesn't like kamala harris
even though trump is mean to anyone who
doesn't like him as we'll see and he's
nice to anybody who does
right that is the common theme of
trumpism there is no
unifying principle other than trump's
ego when it comes to who he likes and
who he doesn't
which means it's hard to call him a
racist or a sexist when he literally
just judges people based on whether they
are nice to him
yeah that is the actual that is the
actual trump doctrine are you nice to me
hey elizabeth warren tried this same
routine by the way she also tried to
blame covid on trump
and which is a despicable character
assault by elizabeth warren
i will note that this is pretty amazing
so elizabeth warren spoke from a
classroom
in springfield massachusetts i do find
it amusing that democrats
chose to speak from classrooms that they
mandate remain
shut down even if it is safe to reopen
classrooms in safe and secure fashion
the same people who are dictating that
they cannot reopen classrooms are
speaking from the classrooms the
classroom is good enough for elizabeth
warren to be in but not your kids
my favorite part of this graphic though
is that in the background somebody took
children's block letters and put blm in
the background
if you're watching this you can see it
in the right hand side of your screen
it's literally they took the letters b l
and m and put them in the cubby holes
so propagandizing via children's toy
good job dnc solid job
here was elizabeth warren another
extraordinarily
non-ego driven non-radical
non-off-putting person
suggesting that covet is on president
trump
today america has the most coveted
deaths in the world
and an economic collapse and both
crises are falling hardest on black and
brown
families millions out of work millions
more trapped in
cycles of poverty millions on the brink
of losing their homes millions of
restaurants and stores hanging by a
thread
this crisis is bad and it didn't have to
be this way
this crisis is on donald trump
and the republicans who enable him
that's astonishing i mean again these
are astonishingly overwrought claims
what would her policy be to have stopped
coveted she doesn't have one
no one has one it's burned through a
bunch of nations what in the world is
she talking about
also why is grant great aunt warren
yelling at everybody
and then then finally she she made the
woman hear me roar pitch again this is
all part of the kamala harris pitch
we organized we persisted we changed
america women power
yeah you you went nowhere elizabeth
warren i mean you got skunked
we all need to be in the fight to get
joe and kamala elected
and after november we all need to stay
in the fight
to get big things done
we stay in this fight so that when our
children
and our grandchildren ask what we did
during this dark chapter in our nation's
history
we will be able to look them squarely in
the eye and say
we organized we persisted
and we changed america wow we persisted
we persisted oh so inspiring so
inspiring
and then she uh went off to write
another recipe for powwow chow so what
a wonderful candidate that was one once
once you won 1024th interesting
elizabeth warren thank you for that
okay the real star of the night however
was barack obama who can never
let anyone overshadow him barack obama
continues to be the only
draw in the democratic party his wife
michelle is the only other draw in the
democratic party the party is completely
built around the obamas at this point
we'll get to barack obama's speech which
was
again it is it is just astonishing it's
an astonishing case in point
of how barack obama is very good at
politics and is incredible at lawing i
mean and those two things are not a
coincidence i mean they are related
barack obama's gaslighting of the
american people about his love for the
constitution and the declaration of
independence it is one of my least
favorite things about
obama's legacy is the way that he was
able to double talk so smoothly i mean
again props to the man for being very
good at his job
also his perversion of the constitution
was unparalleled in his own
administration
his dislike for founding principles and
the principles undergirding the
constitution of the united states it was
obvious from his governance it was
obvious from his rhetoric
and yet the man had the temerity to
stand
in the museum of the american revolution
in front of a display about the
constitution and talk about
constitutional limits on presidential
power i mean it's
it is the gas lighting is incredible it
really really is amazing we're gonna get
to that in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that there's
never a great time to go to the auto
parts
store now a really bad time to go to the
auto parts store also why aren't you
just using the online interwebs anyway
you should be using rockauto.com
rockauto.com is so much easier than
walking into a store and
somebody demanding quick answers of you
about the type and model of your car and
what kind of part you need
and then they offer you a generic part
or they have to order it online anyway
and then they upcharge you for the
shipping and all of that
instead just go to rockauto.com and get
the part direct rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like airlines
do why would you spend up to twice as
much for the same parts
like say you happen to need a delphi
fg1456 fuel pump assembly for a 2005 to
2010 honda odyssey that'll cost you like
354 bucks at a big chain store
you can get that at rock auto for 217
bucks so they have better prices they
have a better selection
you're doing it all online rockauto.com
is a family business they've been
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com right now to
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of
manufacturers see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
shapiro
in there how did you hear about usbox so
they know that we sent you save money
save time go check out rockauto.com
right now again right shapiro in there
how to hear how did you hear about usbox
so they know that we sent you okay so
that brings us to the star of the night
the star of the night barack obama so as
i say barack obama was originally
supposed to close it out which makes
sense
or you want your cleanup hitter to hit
cleanup but he wanted to hand the torch
to kamala
and joe biden is over in the corner
going what about me why
not me i'm the i'm the nominee why
aren't you oh
okay i'll sit down all right i'll just
stay here where am i
who barack obama handed the torch to
come but what he really did was he
he engaged in a vicious partisan speech
now why anybody was surprised by this is
beyond me
barack obama's vicious partisan he's
always been a vicious partisan he's a
chicago politician knife fighter he's
always been a chicago politician knight
fighter the attempt to paint barack
obama as some sort of great unifying
figure is belied by nearly every poll
certainly on on racial matters in the
united states since 2008
americans were far more optimistic about
racial matters when obama entered office
than when he left office there's a
reason for that he's an incredibly
divisive president
he was very politically radical and he
was good at smoothing
over the rhetoric and the media just
loved the guy i mean the media
slobber over him the media have posters
of barack obama on their wall in the
same way that tim robbins had a poster
of raquel welch in his cell in shawshank
redemption
i mean the media just sit there and gaze
at the pictures of barack obama
and think of better times and they play
romantic music they got some barry white
going in the background as you'll see
from the media reaction to this this has
not waned one iota
many of the forces that led to the rise
of donald trump are direct oppositions
to the media worship of barack obama and
the
widespread gap between the perception of
barack obama by the elite and the rest
of the country
much of the rest of the country saw
barack obama as a deeply divisive figure
they liked him personally but they saw
him as deeply divisive they didn't like
his policies very much
the media thought he was just god they
thought he was god embodied
okay so barack obama has always been
partisan and it's not a shock that he
showed up at the dnc and was super
partisan i mean he literally showed up
at john lewis's funeral and was super
partisan
right john lewis died and george w bush
gets up there at the funeral
at the memorial service and gives this
beautiful unifying speech about john
lewis and how he made the country better
and then barack obama gets up there and
he's like
donald trump is trying to change the
election standards to steal votes
it's like oh my god dude this is a
memorial service but you shouldn't have
been shocked by that
he did the same thing after the
attempted massacre in arizona that
shooting that horrible shooting that
that ended with the uh including
the shooting of gabby giffords he went
to a memorial service in arizona and he
politicized gun control there so barack
obama has always been this guy
nothing has changed about barack obama
and barack obama has always been
characterized by this
incredible ability to double talk the
declaration of independence in the
constitution of the united states so he
has
familia he's smart enough to understand
that the principles undergirding the
constitution and the declaration
are natural rights pre-existing
government a limited government
instituted only to protect those rights
and checks and balances to prevent
government from overstepping its
boundaries
in violation of those rights those are
the fundamental principles of the
declaration of independence
and the constitution of the united
states barack obama knows that and just
like every progressive since woodrow
wilson he dislikes that
he doesn't believe there are natural
rights that praise this government he
believes that rights come from
government just like entitlements come
from government
barack obama does not believe that a
limited government ought to protect
rights he believes that an unlimited
government ought to give you things
barack obama does not believe in checks
and balances he believes in whatever
gets the job done
right that's why you got pen in a phone
obama that's why you got daca obama
that's why you got war in libya without
congressional authorization obama
and yet the man has the temerity to get
and he's been doing this throughout his
career so this is nothing new
he has the temerity to get up there and
pretend that he's speaking in the name
of documents that he absolutely abhors
because he thinks that there are
limitations
on the ability of government to bring us
all together in 2012 one of the actual
slogans flashed on the scoreboard at the
dnc
was government is the only thing we
share okay that is barack obama's view
of the world and yet he had the temerity
last night to give this speech
from the museum of the american
revolution a revolution many
parts of which the basic philosophy of
which you reject
and stand in front of a display of the
constitution of the united states
sort of like bob odenkirk in
in better call saul right standing in
his office from breaking bad
in that giant display of the
constitution of the united states so
that was barack obama's backdrop it was
well lit it was well spoken barack
obama's always been a tremendous speaker
it was actually a better speech than
many of the ones he gives in front of a
crowd because when he waits for crowd
applause he looks smug and arrogant
he he does a good job just like michelle
does speaking direct to camera
the man is naturally gifted this way i
mean he really really is good
he's also extraordinarily dishonest so
here is barack obama speaking about the
the ideals of the constitution of the
united states and ignoring
all of the actual ideals of the
constitution of the united states in
favor of pablum
about how what the constitution was
really about was just democracy writ
large now listen the constitution
is pro-people voting but it is not a
pure democracy it is a republican
document that embodies
all sorts of checks and balances
specifically because the founders did
not want mob rule
but here is barack obama reducing all of
america's founding philosophy down to
people vote
no that that is not all of america's
founding philosophy you're leaving out
some pretty key elements there
president obama but that of course is
the point because what he's going to say
is that
he's for quote unquote democracy donald
trump is not for democracy
and and he's going to stand in front of
a display about the constitution in
order to do this
i'm in philadelphia where our
constitution was drafted
and signed it wasn't a perfect document
it allowed for the inhumanity of slavery
and failed to guarantee women and even
men who didn't own property
the right to participate in the
political process
but embedded in this document was a
north star that would guide future
generations
a system of representative government a
democracy
to which we could better realize our
highest ideals
okay again he reduces all of the
philosophy of the founding too people
can vote
and then we can realize quote unquote
our highest ideals now obama has said in
previous speeches
namely his second inaugural address that
those highest ideals are completely
malleable
by time right liberty doesn't have the
same meaning to everybody this is barack
obama's reductionism of the constitution
into a progressive version of what
government ought to be that's what's
happening here and it's important to
note what this is
because this was his tenure right he
transmuted the basic ideals of the
constitution into
something very very different the
founding ideals of the country that led
to women getting the vote and black
americans getting the vote and to people
without property getting the vote
the founding ideal there was not really
all people vote it was more that all
people
are created in the image of god endowed
by their creator with certain
inalienable rights those are the things
that are in the declaration that end up
embodied in the constitution
but the problem is that that embeds a
few further principles that obama
doesn't agree with namely that that you
are endowed buyer created with certain
inalienable rights
rights that cannot be tread on by the
government obama doesn't believe that
kind of thing
right so in a second we'll get to more
of obama's you know continuing
perversion of american philosophy
and then we'll get to what the real core
of the speech was which is donald trump
is very bad and very incompetent and
very bad and also incompetent
it was a very partisan speech again not
shocking from barack obama
and and frankly i'll be honest with you
i really don't care whether presidents
attack their their successors
i don't they've always been political
figures i've always thought that frankly
it's weird that george w bush has
receded from the public scene to the
point where he won't even defend his own
legacy
i understand the tendency to say well
you know presidents shouldn't speak on
political matters beyond their ten
i don't like unwritten rules like that
generally if you're a political figure
obviously you have opinions it's a free
country you should be able to say what
you want so i'm not gonna
i honestly don't begrudge obama getting
political this is what he does
what i begrudge is that he's a partisan
and the media acts as though he is not a
partisan like he's some great unifying
figure who believes in the constitution
when he obviously does not
he routinely overran the boundaries of
the constitution when he was president
we'll get to more of the hypocrisy from
barack obama in just one second
first when you think of your future when
you think of your goals of where you
want to be
well probably you should substitute
dreams for goals and suddenly planning
for your future gets bigger because
nobody has small dreams
instead you can start planning for
fulfilling those dreams by
increasing your educational opportunity
ashford university helps you do it
ashford university's online bachelors
and master's degree programs allow you
to learn on a convenient and flexible
schedule
at ashford expert faculty teach you real
world skills from real world
experience in online classes built for
life's twists and turns they've been
doing online education for
quite a while a lot of universities now
are charging exorbitant amounts of money
for online education and you can get it
better
and faster and less expensively at
ashford
you can pursue a degree in one of
ashford's 60 plus programs like business
administration healthcare administration
and psychology
with 24 7 access to your classroom daily
support and financial aid available
ashford will give you the tools you need
to go from dreaming to doing
don't put off your educational dreams
right now now's a great time for some
resume building go from dreaming to
doing your bigger future starts today at
ashford university no fee to apply or
standardized testing required to enroll
go to ashford.edu that is ashford.edu
slash ben
ashford.edu ben not all programs
available in all states go check them
out
right now it's a great use of time
alrighty we're going to get back to
barack obama then we'll get to
kamala harris who was an afterthought
joe biden is an afterthought kamala
harris is an afterthought
this ticket is just an empty vessel for
we hate trump
as we'll see in just a moment we'll get
to more of that in a second first got to
tell you about our most exclusive
membership tier over at the daily wire
all
access all access members get to join
all access live that is our exclusive
live stream discussions hosted every
night by each of the hosts
including moi tonight august 20th we'll
be doing a very special live stream
watch party covering the dnc's biggest
speakers
with the daily wires own matt walsh i
feel bad for matt just sounds terrible
but that'll make it amusing the stream
starts at 8 45 pm eastern 5 45 pm
pacific
don't miss this big opportunity to tune
in and watch matt walsh mock the dnc
with low key very dry humor all access
membership also features exclusive
access to live online discussions with
our hosts writers and special guests
along with not one but two leftist tiers
tumblers with your membership
as well as early and sometimes exclusive
access to new daily wire products
so head on over to dailywire.com shapiro
right now get 20
off all access with coupon code access
that is dailywire.com
shapiro with coupon code access you get
20 off your membership also
tomorrow we are doing a daily wire
backstage i might want to miss it but
you won't want to
4pm pacific go check us out
dailywire.com slash apparel coupon code
access to get 20
off your membership we have all sorts of
goodies for our members and we're doing
a backstage it's me jeremy boring andrew
clavin michael knowles
and we'll be talking all things dnc rnc
maybe steve bannon related we'll get to
all of that tomorrow so go check it out
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
all right so double talk specialist
barack obama who disdained the
constitution on an ideological level
who thought that its boundaries were
hackneyed and and that the president
should be should be as big a man
as he is capable of being which is a
woodrow wilson line that obama really
did try to apply
he had some words for president trump
now he had two lines of attack
line of attack number one is that trump
had overrun the boundaries of the
constitution that one is just
coming from barack obama i mean that is
take the beam out of your own i dude i
mean that one is that one's pretty wild
his other line of attack is that trump
is not competent right is that trump is
always distractible and this is a line
that was also used the other night by
michelle obama so michelle and barack
are going to do the
we're very competent donald trump is not
very competent routine
and this one has some tell to it right i
mean politically speaking
there's a widespread perception that
donald trump is fragmentary in his
leadership style
to put it to put it at its most obvious
and and it's most mild
that the president is distractible that
the president is not focused
now the good news is that the
constitutional boundaries hem in the
president and he has a team around him
and so that really isn't the end of the
world in terms of policy-making trump's
policy
has been a lot better for the country
than barack obama's policies were
but when it comes to trump's leadership
style and the obvious
sort of volatility and chaos of trump as
a personality
that those are the attacks that obama's
using because his basic idea is and
here's
dead joe over here and dead joe won't be
quite as volatile because
frankly he's not alive so here's barack
obama saying that trump hasn't put in
the work and trump for some reason
decided to underscore the attacks on him
by simultaneously live-tweeting this i
mean it's just
it's beyond political malpractice what
trump has been doing in the last couple
of weeks via twitter anyway here was
obama going after him
i did hope for the sake of our country
that donald trump might show some
interest
in taking the job seriously that he
might come to feel the weight of the
office
and discover some reverence for the
democracy
that had been placed in his care but he
never did
for close to four years now he has shown
no
interest in putting in the work no
interest in finding common ground
no interest in using the awesome power
of his office
to help anyone but himself and his
friends
okay so there are several things here to
unpack one
when he says that trump hasn't put in
the work meaning he he you know is
distractible that one's hard for trump
to rebut when he is on twitter at the
same time tweeting out in all capital
letters his critique of barack obama's
speech
right that is a stupid move by trump it
underscores obama's attack
when obama says that he hasn't under he
hasn't understood the depth of his
office
this is captain selfie over here right
barack obama is the guy who literally
took a selfie stick into the oval office
and was taking pictures of himself with
the selfie stick he was doing interviews
with glozell and pimp with limp
back in 2012. so when it comes to the
seriousness of the office
barack obama was not exactly captain
serious himself
okay beyond that when he says that he's
shown no interest in helping anybody but
himself
a lot of americans were doing great
until covent we had the best economy in
50 years
under donald trump's presidency before
coven there are a lot of folks who are
affected i didn't like criminal justice
reform
criminal justice reform helped a lot of
people right whether you like it or not
it helped a lot of people who
trump obviously wanted to help were not
his political constituency frankly
uh many of them and and he's helped a
lot but donald trump has helped a lot of
people when you talk about
people helping themselves barack obama
was routinely engaged in political
activities that were designed to help
his own political campaigning his own
administration i mean at least
the very least you can say about barack
obama is that when he entered public
office the man was not rich
he he's now worth tens of millions of
dollars donald trump entered public
office being a billionaire and he will
leave a billionaire
so it comes to you know people who have
used politics to make money
barack obama is on that list okay then
obama said that trump hasn't grown into
the job and then he blames trump for 170
000 dead people this is really really
screwless stuff again the line the
democrats are using that trump is
responsible for the number of dead
when again the vast bulk of the dead in
the united states are in
states run by democrats and when it is
clear that no one has a good solution to
coven
is really despicable here is barack
obama being despicable
donald trump hasn't grown into the job
because he can't
and the consequences of that failure are
severe 170
000 americans dead
millions of jobs gone well those at the
top
taken more than ever
our worst impulses unleashed
our proud reputation around the world
badly diminished okay this stuff is crap
okay this is this is where he really
gets demagogic this is demagogic stuff
and saying that trump is responsible for
170 000 deaths is crap trump
him saying that our worst impulses were
only unleashed under under
donald trump at no point in the speech
by the way does he actually
decry the riots happening in major
american cities many of them driven by a
media that hates trump
and mayors that hate trump as well in
fact not only does barack obama not
decry that
at a certain point he actually paid
tribute to it right he just pretends
that everybody's protesting there hasn't
been a riot anywhere
obama said about the protesters you are
the nation's dream fulfilled
really i mean you can make the case that
protesting
is is the and it is true that protesting
is a major part of american tradition
it is not true that rioting and looting
ought to be a major part of american
tradition
and failing to make any distinction or
even to note that that stuff is
happening for three straight nights of
the dnc is pretty incredible
next week the rnc should on a loop show
what's been happening around the country
in terms of the violence the chaos the
rioting and the looting
that's been promulgated by democrats
excused by democrats excused by the
media here's barack obama pretending
that the only thing that's been
happening in the united states is some
nice low-level protest
to the young people who led us this
summer telling us
we need to be better in so many ways you
are
this country's dreams fulfilled earlier
generations had to be persuaded
that everyone has equal worth for you
it's a given
a conviction and what i want you to know
is that for all its messiness and
frustrations
your system of self-government
can be harnessed to help you realize
those convictions okay this is the
inside outside game that democrats have
been playing for quite a while here
which is that
sure the system is great when we run it
when we don't run it we need you out in
the streets
we need to out in the streets and we
need you not only protesting but we'll
excuse your rioting and we'll excuse
your looting and we'll excuse the
violence we'll excuse the messiness
we'll excuse the chaos
because we don't run the government but
when we're in power you need to calm it
down guys because then we got this thing
this is the inside outside game
democrats are playing
okay but obama didn't stop there so
obama then suggested that trump doesn't
believe in american principles
now again how barack obama defines
american principles has been
a long-standing question and this is a
real question like what what are
america's founding principles what are
the creedal principles that unite us i
mean i wrote an entire book about this
how to destroy america in three easy
steps
is about what are the principles that
ought to unite us barack obama disagrees
with many of the founding principles the
idea of natural rights pre-existing
government he does not believe this he
does not believe that government ought
to be limited to protect those rights he
does not believe in checks and balances
he doesn't believe in any of those
things he believes in a culture that
that prizes entitlement
in a culture that disdains social
institutions in favor of governmental
institutions
he doesn't believe in a lot of
foundational american ideals that's not
unique to barack obama
right that is that is a hallmark of the
progressive movement since the beginning
of the 20th century
but here is donald trump suggesting that
trump doesn't this is obama suggesting
trump doesn't believe
in american principles while standing in
front of a a
sign about the constitution of the
united states here is captain pen in a
our phone to work together to solve big
problems like a pandemic
depend on a fidelity to facts and
science
and logic and not just making stuff up
none of this
should be controversial
these shouldn't be republican principles
or democratic principles they are
american principles but at this moment
this president and those who enable them
have shown they don't believe in these
things
okay so american principles according to
barack obama are things like science in
fact and also men and women don't exist
and babies in the womb are not actually
babies they're just clusters of cells so
that's always exciting stuff to hear
from um from president
obama he also went after president obama
for using what he called troops as
political props
again he's focusing in on the lafayette
park incident in which the
national park service cleared the park
before trump walked out to do this photo
op at st
john's church again it's unclear from
the reports
whether these protesters were throwing
objects the cops the park service says
yes many of the protesters in the media
say no
in any case he hearing bro like the
hypocrisy is astonishing hearing barack
obama talking about using troops as
political props
barack obama literally went in front of
at a military base in front of a group
of troops and
said you guys make a great photo op i'm
not kidding that's a thing he actually
said
in real life but here he was saying like
you can't use troops as props i wouldn't
i wouldn't use troops as props except
when i do here's barack obama
they understand that in this democracy
the commander-in-chief
does not use the men and women of our
military who are willing to risk
everything to protect our nation as
political props to deploy against
peaceful protesters on our own soil
yeah again barack obama routinely
routinely did this kind of thing he
stood before troops and said there's a
direct quote you guys make a pretty good
photo op
sure sure okay and then obama concluded
by saying that this administration is
tearing down democracy again this is
coming from the guy who launched war in
libya without congressional
authorization who explicitly said that
he could not simply avoid the
implementation of immigration law and
then just did it
this is coming from the same guy who
sicked his irs on conservative
on conservative 501 c3s but had
plausible deniability
this is the same guy who routinely
engaged in activities that violated the
the long-standing norms of the
constitution
he is now calling for by the way for the
end of the senate filibuster which he
calls racist when five minutes ago he
said that it was actually a tool for
democracy
this guy has no fidelity to
institutional to institutional not only
norms
but to the actual institutions of the
united states if they stand
as an obstacle to his broader
progressive mission and yet here he is
saying the administration's going to
tear down democracy
you're the missing ingredient the ones
who will decide whether or not america
becomes
the country that fully lives up to its
creed
that work will continue long after this
election
but any chance of success depends
entirely
on the outcome of this election this
administration has shown it will tear
our democracy
down if that's what it takes for them to
win
so we have to get busy okay so i mean
what he's saying right now is
so wildly wildly dangerous him saying
that basically the fascists are at the
gates
and if we lose this election then the
country is over is extraordinarily
dangerous
really really dangerous if joe biden
wins this election the country is not
over
it means that a real setback for a lot
of the things i care about not just
politically but philosophically
because i think the democratic party's
enthralled to the 1619 project crowd
but i don't believe that america's
electoral institutions are over
if the democrats win barack obama is
literally saying that
i'm old enough to remember because again
i'm more than 30 seconds old when the
when the media were saying donald trump
is undermining the results of an
election that's bad
democrats have been doing it
consistently for years and barack obama
just did it last night
and uh and that is that is scary stuff
okay so obama gives the speech and the
media are
just gushing over it ryan lizza a
reporter for politico
he actually tweeted out this is a direct
quote from twitter
so much journalism guys i mean the
journalism was just getting everywhere
it got real sticky and messy the
journalism
he tweeted out barack obama just
delivered the finest convention speech
in modern history again
spellbinding chilling optimistic
beautifully written
expertly delivered incredible moment and
then uh he had to sleep it off for a few
for a little while
ryan liza that guy's the white house
reporter for the politico
don't worry the media are they are
even-handed
they show neither fear nor favor rachel
maddow was very
exorbitantly excited about this as well
said obama slayed her slayed her
slay obama slay
president obama's speech tonight slayed
me um
i'm sure people have different opinions
about it because it's a different kind
of thing from him but
his warnings that we could potentially
be at the end of american democracy
um scared me and i found upsetting
and hard to watch um but just powerful
powerful stuff powerful stuff so again
when democrats say we're at the end of
american democracy powerful stuff when
donald trump
suggests that the democrats want to ruin
american democracy terrible stuff
how about it's just not great all around
when you suggest that the other side is
going to end the democracy of the united
states
without any evidence that this is the
case it
amazing uh well done media well done
okay so here's the problem
because obama got all the plaudits that
left kamala harris is kind of left over
and this is just the case for the
democratic ticket joe biden and kamala
harris are not inspiring in any way
shape or form
joe biden is a is a dead person he is
not an alive human
and kamala harris is an incredibly
lackluster candidate she was lackluster
in the primary so lackluster she didn't
last until the first primary
she's not inspiring she she is not
exciting so she gave her speech last
night
and she was low-key kamala because haiki
commonly really
keyed up and pitched up that level of
kamala harris is very off-putting to
voters as we learned in the primaries so
she's gonna go like full mike pence now
she's gonna really tone it down
and basically her entire campaign now is
gonna be i love joe
now five seconds ago she hated joe like
five seconds ago joe was a racist bigot
but now joe's the savior of the country
so heroes kamala harris suggesting that
joe biden would turn our challenges
into purposes this comes the night after
joe biden said that joe biden would make
us whole joe biden can't even make his
mental
acuity hole here was tom o'hara
suggesting that joe biden will turn our
challenges into purposes which by the
way is a really
nice way of saying let no good crisis go
to waste
which is the democratic hallmark that we
are going to use every challenge as an
opportunity to grow government and
overthrow your rights here as kamala
harris last night
right now we have a president who turns
our tragedies
into political weapons
joe will be a president who turns our
challenges
into purpose joe will bring us together
to build an economy that doesn't leave
anyone behind
where a good paying job is the floor
not the ceiling joe will bring us
together
to end this pandemic and make sure
that we are prepared for the next one
okay she was very not good last night i
mean this was kind of the tenor of her
speech she was really not good
she had a couple of lines that were real
clunkers so she she said for example
she's talking about racism and racial
injustice
and she said there's no vaccine for
racism please can we not use coveted
metaphors
at this point it's just awkward like
people are still getting sick from covet
and it ain't a metaphor here
is kamalaris using covet metaphors to
talk about racism or something
let's be clear there is no
vaccine for racism
we've got to do the work
for george floyd for brianna
taylor for the lives of too many others
to name
for our children and for
all of us it turns out that there is in
fact a vaccine for racism you just get
nominated the presidential candidate for
the democrats and then they just got
stopped calling you racist like randomly
like kamala harris did
it turns out the vaccine is being
nominated for high office as a democrat
and then everything just goes away
that's the actual vaccine for racism
my favorite unaware of kamala harris
line last night is she was talking about
how as a prosecutor she went after
various types of predator and and this
one got a lot of play she said that she
knows a predator when she sees one
which is weird and awkward because she
said that she believed
joe biden's sexual assault and
harassment accusers
so she knows a predator when she sees
one unless she's running with one then
so brett kavanaugh yes on the assault
joe biden no on the assault unless it's
yes on the assault but if he nominates
her it's no on the assault here's kamala
harris predator spotter
i have fought for children and survivors
of sexual assault
i fought against transnational criminal
organizations
i took on the biggest banks and helped
take down one of the biggest for-profit
colleges
i know a predator when i see one do you
though
um because you you literally suggested
you're running mate as predator
so there is that okay so the the
convention final notes on night three
obama's still the star of the show he is
a he's a gifted politician who lies a
lot
which may be synonymous kamala harris is
lackluster joe biden is lackluster a lot
of lackluster stuff
going on this should open a gap for
trump because again they're making this
entire election a referendum on two
topics essentially
covid which theoretically could get
better and trump personally
right that trump is a mean very very bad
man which would require trump to stop
stop stop stop so here's the thing you
shouldn't do so yesterday again this is
such a political malpractice he was
asked about q anon president trump and i
have to note this before we close
right president trump was asked about q
and on q anon is this bizarre conspiracy
theory that has been floating around
reddit for years
same sort of people who suggest that
that comet
ping pong pizza or whatever the hell
that that pizza shop is in washington dc
was actually
a child predator grooming site or some
such stupid garbage
they have this theory that donald trump
is protecting people from cannibalism
and that he is the head of some group
called q and that he is trying to
prevent
the the deep state from satanic rituals
or something like
it's it's totally crazy insane garbage
stupid garbage stupid crap right
well over the last week the president
endorsed a candidate in georgia who won
a
congressional primary who is a q anon
believer
apparently and then the president
endorsed laura loomer
who is a rather nutty character at the
very least who said some pretty
egregious things
from florida and uh and so people were
asking him
so he was asked about q anon and this
would be a good time for the president
of the united states to either shut the
hell up
and say i don't know anything about q
and on i'll study it and get back to you
like i really don't know anything i'm
not into internet culture
or for him to say q anon is a terrible
stupid conspiracy theory i have no idea
why people believe it and it's idiotic
instead because everything in president
trump's world
is viewed through the prism of do they
like me or do they not like me
do they love me love me not love me kim
jong-un love me
vladimir putin love me not like because
everything is viewed that way
through this personal prism you get this
incredible answer from the president
about q and on
which in a time when you are being
attacked by your political opposition is
unfocused and conspiratorial
is a crazy answer just not a polit
forget the morality of it which is
ridiculous
the political nature of this is so
unbelievably stupid undermining yourself
this way
what's he thinking what here the answer
is nothing right here's the president
being like
the q9 people like me so i guess i like
them too love
the q anon movement has been appears to
be gaining a lot of followers
can you talk about what you think about
that well i don't know much about the
movement other than i understand they
like me very much
uh which i appreciate the theory it is
this belief that
you are secretly saving the world from
this satanic
cult of pedophiles and cannibals is that
supposed to be a bad thing or a good
thing i mean you know
if uh if i can help save the world from
problems i'm
willing to do it i'm willing to put
myself out there okay so a couple things
one he doesn't know what kunan is it's
perfectly obvious he doesn't
two he will literally say nice things
about anyone who says they like him
right i mean that's that's what this
comes down to so the media are drawing
the conclusion that he's actually like
giving credence to cunanan
well he kind of is because he doesn't
know what it is that that answer should
have ended with
i don't know much about them but as
always president trump's answer
continues to do they like me or not
i just like john lewis i don't know much
about him but he didn't come to my
inauguration so he's a poo-poo head
like why would you do this why the
entire critique that obama laid at your
feet
is that you are being distractible and
unserious and that you are willing to
grant credence to silly things
there are 90 days till the election if
trump wants to remain president he needs
to buckle down
democrats are making this entire thing a
referendum on covet which could wane i
think actually it is on the wane by
statistics
so that's good for trump but then
they're really making it a referendum on
him personally
which means he needs to cool his jets no
more the all caps tweeting
calm your ass down sir if you wish to
remain president
and also don't say stupid terrible
things like that that's that's not good
okay so
we'll be back here later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow
for recap of joe biden's big ascension
to the democratic nomination he's going
to give
his speech and presumably there will be
three intelligible sentences we'll break
down all three of them tomorrow i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick shien the
show is edited by adam syavets
audio mix by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clinton